- So I hear you seem to find
a piano wherever you travel,
is this a thing you love to do?
- Well, I've never met
a piano I didn't like.
- I like that.
- Yeah.
- That's 'cause you're good at it.
- Every once in a while I'll be somewhere
and there'll be a piano somewhere.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- [Craig] And I'll just
pop up and sit down.
Yeah. Yeah.
- [Kelly] Especially, like the bar
at the hotel you're
staying at or something,
I feel like they always have one.
- [Craig] Yeah. That's happened for sure.
I think that was in Austin.
- Austin, Texas?
- Yes. Yeah.
- Oh man, they probably loved it.
- Oh yeah. Yeah.
They came around and we
were, you know, being silly.
- [Kelly] It's like
music city there, yeah.
- We just did a whole little
show right there. Yeah.
- What's like a- What's the best-
Do you have like the
most memorable moment,
something's happened like that?
You just sat down and
something cool happened?
- Oh (chuckles), I was at this party.
and Mick Jagger was there.
- [Kelly] What?
- Not- And it wasn't like Mick
Jagger happened to be there.
It was a party, we were
doing this movie Get On Up.
- Yeah.
- And they had a party at this
this guy's house somewhere,
we were in Mississippi,
and Mick Jagger's one of the producers,
so he was, but then he got around,
the piano was just singing
tunes with us. Yeah.
- That's crazy.
- It was amazing.
I wish I had that picture for you.
- Oh my god. I swear I
would've laughed while singing.
Like, what is- why is-
- Oh, it was, yeah, it was just, it was-
- I love moments like that,
- I was on a cloud.
- it's like a movie.
- Yeah.
- I was on a cloud.
- That's so cool.